and tonight we begin in the D.C swamp
where yet again it's Washington versus
the rest of us as our sense of
sovereignty and our sense of safety and
our sense of security are all under
attack and the culprits sadly are our
own elected leaders who just can't be
bothered to care because as it turns out
the massive 1.7 trillion dollar Omnibus
spending bill being rammed through
Congress does little to nothing for as
an example U.S border security all while
Democrats and frankly some Senate
Republicans of course continue to shrug
off the worst border crisis in modern
American history that is hurting
Americans more and more by the day yet
again this week video shows illegal
migrants pouring across the border
overwhelming authorities with no end in
sight and get this in just the last year
there were well over one hundred
thousand overdose deaths here in the
United States as drugs continue to pour
across the southern border and take
innocent American lives in 2022 alone
the DEA seized enough fentanyl everybody
get this to kill everybody in our entire
country but for the far left Democrats
it's low on the list of priorities as
Senate democrats for the third time
blocked Republican senator Bill
hagerty's legislation to crack down on
fentanyl crossing the border and
remember Biden's border crisis is so bad
that every state of course is now a
border state cities across the country
are bracing for an even worse influx
once title 42 border protections are
eventually lifted for example New York
city mayor Eric Adams is predicting that
over one thousand migrants a week will
arrive in New York City early next year
with the mayor warning that the surge
will impact access to basic Services
meant for New York City's legal
residents which are of course already a
problem here this is a crisis caused by
Joe Biden enabled by Joe Biden and
getting worse under Joe Biden and the
Democrats but many elected leaders they
don't seem to care as once again in
Washington the interests of everyday
Americans take a back seat to the
interests of the swamp here for reaction
someone you know and like and Trust
former Hawaii congresswoman Tulsi
gabbard welcome aboard look you when you
left the Democratic party you mentioned
that you were getting the sense and it
was unacceptable to you that Washington
had stopped caring about average
Americans about regular people with what
I opened with here what's your take on
where we stand right now
yeah I mean you're exactly right Tammy
that's really what's at the heart of
this is we have Democrats and
Republicans frankly in Congress who are
failing at their most basic and foremost
responsibility which is to ensure the
safety security and freedom of the
American people and that starts with
securing our border we don't have a
country if we don't have a secure border
now you talked about this 1.7 trillion
dollar funding bill that the Senate just
passed and the house will pass very
likely soon well there's there's about
1.5 billion there that's been set aside
for Customs and Border Protection border
security the problem is the language
also says they're not actually allowed
to use any of that money to secure the
Border they can't use it to expand their
security capabilities so when you look
at what they're actually doing
ultimately they either don't care as you
said or they are purely incompetent
either way they're failing at their jobs
they need to step up to the plate and do
their job or they need to be replaced so
it's fascinating it's one thing to put
it in without specifying what it should
be used for but they go out of their way
to say don't use it for security don't
touch that and in the meantime exactly
you know every issue that we find at the
border Tulsi relates to every major
issue in the country crime the wage Gap
problem uh the the diseases health
issues inflation the economy in general
it's like every housing issues right
you've got people putting the migrants
in hotels and the homeless and hotels
we've got veterans now still on the
street but we we I think the American
people don't realize what's happening at
the border and really how it is linked
to every single thing that we're facing
and what American families are dealing
with
and and Tammy as you look as you're
listing out all of these challenges that
that are facing just about every
Community across this country look I
served in the municipal government I was
on the Honolulu city council I served in
the state legislature in Congress for
eight years so often we are told in our
communities sorry from the federal
government there's just not enough money
right as we see in this 1.7 trillion
dollar bill they're sending hundreds of
millions of dollars to secure other
countries borders they're spending an
incredible amount of money to feed into
the military-industrial complex but not
willing to do what is necessary to
secure our own border and support the
needs of the American people uh right
here at home there's a lot to be done at
the board there's a lot that should be
done at the border things like hey let's
deploy more of the National Guard that
you're seeing on the screen right there
to actually supplement and provide this
immediate need to help secure our border
fix this broken Asylum process send a
message very clear both from our elected
leaders and those who want to serve in
office to the world saying from here on
out if anyone comes across across our
border illegally you will be immediately
deported and you will not be allowed to
re-enter our country period you know
we'll stop this this release of title 42
has been an incentive so regardless of
what happens with this point of uh of
temporarily stopping it from the Supreme
Court it's too late this has been going
on for months this lead up and you
remember when this first began when
Biden first came in they called what was
it El Paso the new Ellis Island do you
remember that I mean that was an
invitation if I ever heard one
exactly and yet they have the audacity
over and over again to say oh no our
borders are are not open we don't have
open borders you look at the proof and
you look at the crisis that we are
facing at the border right now as you
mentioned people literally thousands of
people crossing hour over hour waiting
for this uh Supreme Court hold on title
42 to be lifted in anticipation that
they will be able to walk straight
through without any repercussions
whatsoever because that's exactly what's
been happening yeah and the money I have
to say thank you so much for joining us
tonight the little bit of money that
they're sending it's like we're turning
into a big travel agency because it's
about facilitating their entry and then
Distributing them into the interior of
the country Tulsi great job great to see
you hey Sean Hannity here hey click here
to subscribe to Fox News YouTube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis you will not
get it anywhere else